it's joint work with a bunch of people a
Tomatina
Sam Jacque I hope I pronounced that name
correctly mission Erik Matthias Sirkin
and fernando vidya fernando is here too
there hey over there we were super happy
to have two brilliant interns last year
fernando and sam and the lion's share of
that work is due to them so the idea of
that work is basically the other end of
the spectrum compared to the asymptotic
analysis we heard about in the morning
so what we want to do is we want to cost
out basically at the bit level the cost
it takes to break some crypto schemes so
the the schemes were looking at here are
a s on one hand and low MC so those are
the two schemes we implement it and on
the exponential speed-up side we're
Shor's algorithm in particular for
elliptic curve d logs so i'm going to
show you how to implement those
algorithms in queue sharp and first I
want to introduce real quick what that
is so if you sharp is Microsoft's
programming language there are many many
programming languages and many of them
are really great Microsoft has their own
flavor it's called Q sharp it's part of
a bigger offering called the development
kit and part of that offering is Q sharp
with the compiler there are simulators
and resource estimators and I'm going to
say a little bit more about what they
are in a moment and what's important is
they're a huge chunk of libraries
libraries is what you need to get
started to actually write down
algorithms they're already several
libraries out there samples are examples
that teach concepts in the language are
also many here and what we really love
is kata Skoda's are really simple
exercises ranging from just implement a
harder mark aid to implement dojo saw
and and beyond but it thinks there are
self-paced you can start learning the
language that way and you always get
immediate feedback there unit test said
you're right you have to pass all the
unit tests and that's that's how you
learn the language it's all free it's
under the MIT license so it's an
open-source license you can contribute
back to Q shop if you want to and also
the work I'm going to show here is also
open source so it's available at that
address
and roughly the idea is the following so
we want to have a language that's very
high level ideally would even don't even
have to reason about circuits so you can
reason about circuits but you don't
after that's the aspiration and because
circuits are not really a scalable
concept right when you think about it
having thousands of qubits having
billions of gates you don't really want
to think about the circuit so much you
definitely don't want to visualize the
circuit anymore at that level right you
want to get metrics about the circuit
but you don't want to look at the
circuit it's all black in a sense right
we won't have that many that many
circuit that many qubits so the idea is
to express a program high-level and at
scale and the language allows you to do
that we distinguish two different types
of operations so operations themselves
are two quantum operations that you're
right think about how to Mart's
clifford's T gates and so on whereas
functions are classical helper functions
you might need underway right think of
it like that you do a measurement based
on the result you do another decision
what you do next in your algorithm so
you get that adaptive flavor of your
algorithm to support that we have
functions there libraries to implement
both but the user and typically he or
she writes a program that uses those and
have their own operations and functions
it might also have a driver a classical
program we just gather and then you post
process what you learned
right Shor's algorithm is a good example
you do some continued fraction expansion
at the very end it's entirely classical
it can be offloaded into a classical
programming language once that's all
written then you can target various
backends so of course we'd like to have
target quantum hardware scalable
hardware doesn't exist yet but the
program that you write today in the
future you don't have to modify it you
can use it and run it on the hardware
ideally once it's there in the meantime
you can run it against simulators and
you can run it against resource
estimators so resource estimators what's
that well basically it's a profiler
right it runs through a program it
counts how many qubits are there how
many T gates are there how many scene
arts what is there right what is the
basic profiling information so what you
see here is a chemistry application and
we implemented here two different
methods to do the same basically a
Hamiltonian simulation one is trotter
ization and another is a qubit ization
which is a method we heard in the
morning about it's a block encoding
technique both are implemented in Q
sharp and you can use it to do well up
to some size of course right you can you
can
the resource estimation of those
hamiltonians and would also cool is if
your circuit belongs to special family
say Clifford circuit we have a classical
algorithm to simulate them right and
hopefully circuits as well if you have
just a classical input to your TOEFL II
then you can still simulate it of course
not a general input but if it's stress
achill a bit vector you can simulate it
and there's support for that in the
language so it's that's good to write
unit tests right so you you express your
entire shor arithmetic in in an open e
network and then you test it out and you
find bugs early on let me talk a little
bit about how we do a s so this is what
it looks like in in Q sharp so don't
worry if you can't read it so that the
bottom line is just it's really
literally the loop you would expect over
square root of capital n May iterations
and then there's a duration of two
reflections right alternation of two
reflections when you drill it down
basically it's you know as you all know
it has the sequential flavor right many
applications of the same operator and
when you drill that further down as you
pop it open there is this what we call
in quantum computing Oracle right way
all the complexity really sets the rest
is basically just a NAND gate at a bunch
of other Mart's and when you drilled
that further open for special case of
AES then you see several boxes that
implement decipher the forward
evaluation of the cipher reversibly
right so that was state-of-the-art
like a couple years ago we thought we
need three boxes for 128 bits for 492
and five for 256 those are the three
flavors of AES turned out that was
actually very wasteful analysis so part
of the last summer when when Fernando
looked at the problem we realized that
we need only two boxes for 128 bits to
492 and three for 256 there was another
group that came to the same conclusion
around the same time I'm gonna mention
them later but curve dead that already
chops down the number of qubits
significantly it also chops down the
number of gates but there were more
improvements and so let's look at the
algorithm a little bit closer so a es
forward consists of just like a key
expansion and then
many rounds where you have an SS box
internally and the S box is essentially
finite field inversion so we implemented
that in Q sharp and the the the most of
the savings came by a smart way to do
that s box so there's a great paper as
the classical result by by Boyle and
Peralta and they came up with a very low
complexity implementation of the S box
and complexity is measured in terms of
how many and functions you need that's
called the multiplicative complexity of
the function and that chops down already
significantly as you can see the C knots
and the T gates T gates are the
dominating cost in fault tolerant
implementations it was a slight like
increase of qubits whether the TTIP
savings are dramatic and there were
further savings that we found by
improving that the key expansion key
expansion before was done in a wasteful
way the qubits were not reused and it's
possible to reduce qubits off and that's
that that you can see that drop here
this code is available we have a paper
and you can get that code for free oh
okay that I should mention this as well
so this is a special Easter egg that
NIST left us in the in a call namely a
introduction of max steps right they
said okay no no quantum algorithm can
use more than that depth right and they
gave three choices and there were
justifications for those choices but
what it really means is that we had to
rely had to reason about hey what
happens if the max steps is two to the
4d if it's whatever right then we were
forced to parallel lies right because
you cannot do a deeper computation and
Grover unfortunately does not parallel
lies well right it doesn't pair like
classically you can chop if you have two
processors you can distribute ideally
the load and you can double the speed
right quantumly unfortunately it's not
the case so but still we had to analyze
it and the result of the analysis can be
found in the paper it heavily depends on
what your max steps is what you can
achieve we improve over the best known
state of the art by several orders of
magnitude basically three three orders
of magnitude are our improvements of
course still these algorithms are not
algorithms we want to run this is all
just about the security parameters of
those schemes right nobody wants to run
the quantum
but that many gates but we have these
rough estimates and as I said the papers
the code can be found online also I can
quickly show you so there's github repo
where you can clone it and then if you
if you want to run you can just this
runs on across many different platforms
if you can type it should work it runs
on oops why does all this doesn't pick
it up this is interesting I'm on a
virtual desktop here all this pretty
does not do it that sucks it is yes
maybe have to exit a PowerPoint virtual
desktops okay if it slows me down three
orders of magnitude oh shoot
okay that's a good point
[Music]
extend
folks
yeah okay sorry about that so you can
clone the the the code on github and I
just wanted to show that real quick this
is what you can do with it so yes for
instance that those are the files to
support it you can get the code for
instance in Visual Studio code see the
code here if you want to run it it runs
across multiple platforms
you can run it on basically whatever
supports dotnet core and that max2
supported Windows Linux supports it and
then this this gives you the the Oracle
itself it gives you the resource
estimates the T gates to see knots and
so on and you can modify this stuff if
you have your own hash function do you
want to implement basically all the
infrastructure is there you can you can
run it it goes through all the
components that are needed for AES all
these kind of key expansion some key and
kind of it goes through all of them
picks up the cost and at the end you get
also the aggregated cost then you have
to cost for the Oracle itself what we
did then the rest of the analysis we did
by hand like there the reasoning about
parallelization of the algorithm we did
that part by hand does that answer the
question okay let me shift gears and
talk a bit about T log because at the
high level it's a similar approach we
write a library for the point Edition
but of course the arithmetic there is
very different so whereas in AES you
have a lot of bit level operations like
at the bit level addition or XOR
shifting of bits ECC d log is dominated
by modular arithmetic that means that I
kind of have a look at this this is
typical a typical formula that you can
find on Dan and Tania's database of like
point addition formulas that are out
there for elliptic curves there are many
many ways you can represent the curve
and in many ways you can implement the
addition we picked one we picked a
biased
f-fine by a stress form for the elliptic
curve and then what your face is a lot
of finite field operations
multiplication addition inversion and
inversion is by far the most costly
operation as you might imagine because
how do you do actually inversion well
you have to do Euclidean Euclidean
algorithm and the twist here is that you
have to do it reversibly so you have to
in superposition you have to invert
elements and the twist is that the
Euclidean algorithm does not have a
uniform runtime right the different
inputs might require a different number
of
steps so you have to uniform it uniform
it kind of make it really form that you
do the exact same operations no matter
what the input is so that's that's the
complication here we used a particular
representation of the numbers called
Montgomery representation and then yeah
it looks essentially like the binary
euclidean algorithm what you need to
implement so we had done that earlier in
the paper into 2017 but it was wasteful
so in the internships what we found was
that one of the registers could be
flat-out eliminated it was completely
unnecessary to to introduce that and
instead of four inversions here we could
actually get away with two and also
there was an an unnecessary squaring
step so all these things together led to
reductions in cubed count and gate
counts and then if you look at a table
those were that line here was the
previous known best results 239 we
brought it down by by almost two orders
of magnitude so instead of 100 million T
gates to do short two thousand bit it
now encodes only takes roughly a billion
T gates and the number of qubits also
came down mainly by eliminating that one
register if you're compared to RSA
there's a whole technology about
comparison I don't want to get into
there but once one school of thought
compares 256 bit of ECC to RS a 3000 and
when you look at the cubed numbers
they're they're higher and also T gates
are significantly higher and the
takeaway from there is it's easier to
attack the ECC D lock for comparable
security parameters then it is our as
there is for RSA the techniques were
unrolling of while loops that was the
main improvement but also windowing was
was a technique we used we basically
learned and adapted techniques there we
learn from a paper by Craig Gidney and
Martin acara they introduced these
techniques and they're very powerful
they lead to a lot of savings in the
gates and that's it thank you very much
for your attention
[Applause]
great until it's a check understood
currently the improvement in short just
came from doing more efficient and it
took every 30 um good question so the
question was does the improvement in
Shor's algorithm only from doing better
elliptic curve arithmetic so there was
three sources basically of improvement
one was to realize that we did not one
of the intermediate results we could
basically in place update of the
variables there was one the other one
was in the unrolling of the loop
there were several improvements we could
do better and there were local
improvements like the square we could
eliminate and the third one was at the
top level when you look at shorts
algorithm it has a bunch of bits and
then it does these conditional additions
of multiples of a point
it's called classically known points we
did windowing at that level so basically
we knowing means to cache you pre
compute some stuff you make small tables
and there's a sweet spot for the size of
those tables so we did that and we then
got your improvements and and and mind
you those are all implemented all these
the entire arithmetic is all implemented
and tested at scale so those are the
actual circuits that you would one-day
run on the computer and we run them to
test vectors and they all correct so the
only quantumness missing is the harem
art and a phase gate and another harder
Mart and the rest is all this classical
arithmetic that happens in between and
that's all implemented here and queue
shop basically you push a button it
counts all the gates and it checks it
you have different optimizations for
their quantum setting over the past
oh that's a great so the question is is
that different optimizations quantumly
versus classically the answer I think
the honest answer is we don't really
know yet
classically people optimize for instance
Dan Tania correct me if I'm wrong
optimize for square because squares are
cheaper than divisions right classically
so we don't know if the same intuitions
hold true here will be actually great to
try out many different group
representations many different group
laws and do an automatic estimates one
complication there's some technical
complications there due to which we have
not been able to go beyond wire stress
forms so far it's not so easy to work
with projective coordinates on a quantum
computer if you really want to do it at
a bit level and that's the main issue I
don't know if that answers your question
good question is that logical qubits or
physical qubits one answer to questions
[Laughter]
choose my words Wow
yeah all all logical yeah we could do a
footprint type of analysis where we just
multiply the number out I'm not taking
into account any more sophisticated
mapping of the circuit but this is all
logical to solve
that's that yeah because I mean I'm sort
of a little bit puzzled but I mean this
non parallelization of growver is sort
of difficult yeah I mean you still seem
to have some advantage in your analysis
with I guess a reasonable weights I
think you called it yeah but now if you
take error correction into account yeah
that's that's good point maybe you don't
yeah yeah the question is whether if we
take into account fault tolerance and
error correction if we still have an
advantage and I think the honest answers
we don't know because the overhead could
be quite significant for making it fall
tolerant yes Vlad yeah you have properly
networks I guess right that's how you
test these circuits or otherwise I don't
see how we can yes yes the question is
if we have hopefully networks underlying
the circuits and yeah the answer is yes
we do there is one little twist to it so
we have to do to write the unit tests on
to test the circuits we use the toughly
networks because then we can feed in a
classical test vector send it through a
toughy network and check they forget
their writers to the resource estimates
then we can do a little bit better like
it awfully simply other naively Maps 270
gates but there ways to do it hopefully
with 40 gates and measurement right if
for like kidney has a paper I think
Salinger earlier a paper so you can
actually do it by force you get like an
improvement of 4/7 and we didn't want to
miss out on that improvement so how
would we do it well the same Q sharp
program once can be run against at
awfully tester but then you can run the
same program and run it against a way to
map that hopefully two different T gates
you see in the resource estimate and a
tracer we then had a different way to
break it down so we actually their
numbers for your report use the 40 gates
per table gate does that doesn't answer
[Applause]